no but uh I swallow well and um shift
getting removed I think is a good thing
swallows definitely there was very
legitimate reasons to kick him off and
shift too shift said shift was an evil
guy he lied changes in the house Intel
committee which is about intelligence
and he was lying about it saying that he
had um direct evidence of collusion
between Trump and Russia so I mean
there's no credibility there with that
pencil neck shift As Trump used to call
him what about uh what about Omar though
I think that she's pretty that's all I
have to say about her and She Bangs her
brother allegedly but I you were talking
last night about Matt Gates's position
on this and how he's very logically
consistent which I agreed with so he's
saying that she he's a plant he's using
he's applying her own standard that's
why she should be removed because she
said that when it came to was it Apollo
star and murder Taylor green yep over
the space lasers right I I can't believe
the space lasers story has come full
circle with Republican party and
Marjorie Taylor green there are actual
space
Alex Jones of Congress